what happens to Yellow fabric when it's  placed into scp-914 researcher Salas  selected one spool of yellow fabric for  experimentation with the Clockworks the  fabric was placed into the Machinery on  the setting fine the output produced was  one yellow hoodie that appears black  when exposed to light levels of .002 Lux  or higher when not exposed to sufficient  levels of light the outfit glows at 15  000 lumens research staff were rendered  temporarily blind during testing and the  hoodie was incinerated researcher Salas  noted the clothing seems to act as a  light sponge of sorts absorbing light  during normal conditions and releasing  it when the surrounding area gets dark